There's something seriously wrong with the people here.
Like that woman over there.
What does she think she's doing?  I'll tell you what.  A disservice.
She is totally conforming to the image that man and society says that she needs to be.
I'm pretty sure that's like the 3rd saddest thing I've seen all day.
What was the saddest?
That documentary about how plants feel pain.
And earlier today, I saw that this albino squirrel was trying to like mate with
regular brown furred squirrels
but they like wouldn't have him!
And it's not that I feel sad that he can't mate.
But it's like how sad do you have to be to feel such a need to be part of an uneclectic  group?
You know?
I'm going to go ahead and challenge you right there, Jane
because I don't think "uneclectic" is a word.
It's just "eclectic."
Uh, okay Oliver.
Do you see what you just did to me, Oliver?
You attacked me.
No Jane.  But, I do want to apologize if you feel attacked.
Thank you, Oliver.
Though you shouldn't because this, this right here that I'm doing
--it's a learning experience.
Not a battle.
(scoffs) Okay
Well war is so far removed from my school of thought
that I'm not going to acknowledge that you just said the word "battle" to me.
Atticus: Ok guys--
Oliver: Though you just did.
Hypothetically.
Reality.
Rhetorically.
Still just reality.
"Uneclectic" is a word because it makes sense to me.
Maybe when I self-publish my millennial new free-form dictionary you'll get that.
Guys, if I could finish what I was saying.
Oh I'm sorry Atticus, were you trying to say something?
I was.  Though Jane did have an excellent point about the woman in the suit.
That's really gross.
But I was actually talking about the people around Princeton in general.
Like I was at this party last night, off Prospect Street,
just trying to have an intellectual discourse and these
Princetonian elitists come up to me and try to imply that I wasn't on their level.
Wow.
Yeah.
So, you know what I said?
"Listen Sweetie, if you think that intelligence is something that can be measured in levels
then maybe you just need to reevaluate your entire life."
Wow, you actually said that?
I did.
What did they say?
Well I mean they didn't get it but
at the risk of sounding hubristic, I don't think anybody at that entire party had the mental bandwidth
to even handle that kind of ideology.
I can definitely relate to that.
I feel like that at every party I've ever attended, actually.
Yeah, and even in class people aren't ready for new ideas.
It's sad, really, but what are you going to do?